[Music]
CNNMoney reporting Amazon didn't kill
Toys R Us here's what did it's true
online shopping didn't help matters but
the struggles of Toys R Us predate the
boom in online shopping many of its
wounds were self-inflicted the company's
biggest problem it was saddled with
billions of dollars in debt that debt
stopped it from making the necessary
investment in stores and that meant an
unpleasant shopping experience that
doomed the chain the company told
employees Wednesday that it would close
or sell its Us stores after 70 years in
business if you're going to have that
breadth of inventory you need someone in
the store to help you find it help you
experience it said Greg Patel lead
partner at retail consultant 80 Kearney
it's hard to sell toys in a cold
warehouse environment Toys R Us debt
problems date back to well before Amazon
was a major threat its debt was
downgraded to junk bond status in
January of oh five at a time when Amazon
sales were just four percent of the
current level much of the chains
resources were devoted to paying off
that massive debt load rather than
staying competitive Toys R Us filed for
bankruptcy in September 2017 it
disclosed it had about five billion in
debt and was spending about four hundred
million a year just to service that debt
I Heart Radio also found chapter 11
bankruptcy last week on 20 billion
dollars and a bunch of their radio
stations carry this show we're glad that
they're on the air and we're glad to be
on the air with them but it's the same
exact situation the debt there's nothing
wrong I Heart Radio the operations are
clean the app works the one the largest
owner of radio stations in America they
do a good job they're good operators
they're not incompetent we work with
them all the time no problems really
other than 20 billion in debt
and it's just a hard to operate under
that kind of yoke around your neck
because see here's what it does like
here's what happened with Toys R Us okay
Toys R Us started to realize that they
needed to have an online presence and
become a click and mortar Papa Dave that
would be me actually bought grandkids
stuff on Toys R Us website but their
website was clunky this high friction
very hard to operate very hard to
navigate through and you know given
clunky most people are going to click
old prime over at Amazon right you don't
want to clunky you want to quick easy
checkout right boom I'm out of here and
the problem is that same stinking toy
just about every times over there on
Amazon so you're not just competing on
toys you're competing on the way your
website operates the marketplace moved
and if you don't move with the
marketplace you get taken out and so
because they were so saddled in debt
they could not do the investments in
their website infrastructure that they
needed to in the robustness of their
website the elegance of their website
the ease of use for their website if
they had poured four hundred million
dollars a year into their website
because they didn't have debt five
billion dollars in debt they had to give
that money to they'd still be here as
the problem wasn't that they didn't have
a good selection the problem wasn't that
they were bad people we've got a Toys R
Us right about a quarter of a mile from
this office where I'm sitting right now
and I have shopped in there since our
children were little its its iconic it's
a shame that that chain is gone I mean
it was a wonderful I had you know I you
know when our kids had friends that
worked in there in high school we've
bought kids stuff their grandkids stuff
their birthday party stuff they're some
of the first Ramsey kids shopping
experiences were in that particular
store just down the street here what
killed them it was
that they could not respond to the
disruption in the market the disruption
in the market being something like
Amazon and the fact that people are now
doing more and more online ordering and
their online ordering sucked they could
not respond they knew they needed to I
think they do not have any discussions
with their leadership team but I I think
they knew they needed to they didn't
have any money
if they had poured four hundred million
dollars into their infrastructure on
their website I think they'd still be
here because I think they were an iconic
brand and here's what's interesting when
they were rising went that when they
were coming up you know what people in
small towns were saying I don't see if
you're not old you don't know this but
when old people like me I remember we
used to have independent toy stores in
virtually every town just like you had
an independent hardware store before
Home Depot and Lowe's and virtually
every town and oftentimes you had you
know little independent clothing stores
that you know Walmart let's come in and
take it out so what's happened is those
little independence got took out taken
out because they didn't adapt Toys R Us
took them out a decade ago I mean a
generation ago and so what happens in
business is one hundred percent of time
there's going to be a disruption 100
percent of the time there's going to be
change and if you are deeply in debt in
your business just like in your personal
life you don't have the ability to be
nimble float like a butterfly sting like
a bee and go with the change you can't
move
when the market moves because you're
paying a stupid Bank because you
stupidly signed up for so much you can't
breathe in debt payments but if you can
move when a disruption comes along the
disruption can actually become the
biggest blessing to your business
instead of a threat to your business
give you a great example of that
in the 1920s we used to have I didn't I
wasn't here but we Americans had little
boxes in our kitchen that were little
insulated boxes to hold a big cube of
ice called ice boxes because there
wasn't a refrigerator in your kitchen
yet and companies would deliver those
blocks of ice with big tongs and those
blocks of ice would keep your food cool
in your kitchen or you used a cellar
Frigidaire a division of General Motors
invented a thing called freon and
refrigeration was born
now everybody had refrigerators in there
in their living room in their kitchens
and they didn't need ice anymore you
know what the ice houses did a bunch of
them went out of business you know what
one of them in Texas did they started
selling eggs and bacon and other goodies
out of their store the store was called
7-eleven they adjusted to the disruption
this is the Dave Ramsey show